i caught up with this year's kids choice
awards co-host miranda cosgrove and rob
gronkowski and oh yes rob weighed in on
tom brady's 40-day retirement
back i didn't think it was going to be
that quick i mean i know the guy loves
football like no other uh you know he
lives and dies for it maybe he's just
gonna take a year off or so but i knew
he's gonna make it back eventually but
he was in retirement a lot less than we
all anticipated he should be the guy
that should get slimed at the kids
choice award gronk should know he's been
prepping to host the kids choice awards
tomorrow on nickelodeon with icarly's
miranda cosgrove
a lot of sliming let me tell you that
climbing yes did you say a thousand one
thousand signings during the show for
the first time ever okay who is on your
mus slime bucket list i think it'd be
fun to slime adele and i think katy
perry probably had like the best like
craziest sliming at the kids choice
words of anybody ever
miranda's been making headlines over
this viral tick tock moment oh i
actually do cuss a little do you also
what's your favorite curse word probably
like everyone on tick tock thinks it's
me laughing but it's my friend whitney
laughing and i keep texting her like you
framed me
i know all of tick-tock it's like making
fun of me
no but also how you said probably bleep
is so innocent and then it's like
like evil
but yeah it's really funny i love seeing
all the videos it's hilarious the video
brought on parodies including lizzo and
joe jonas with wife sophie turner what's
your favorite curse word
[Music]
you